IT THE NEED TO TRUMP ANGLE.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
THE PAST FEW DAYS HAVE CONVINCED
ME MORE THAN EVER THAT THE
DEMOCRATS AND THEIR AMERICAN
MEDIA ARE FEVERISHLY ATTEMPTING
TO USE THE HASHTAG #METOO 4s
UNDOING.
NOW THAT THEY HAVE EXTRACTED
THIS AND THE BUDGET BILL, THEY
HAVE ESSENTIALLY GIVEN UP ON THE
IDEA OF WORKING WITH THE
REPUBLICANS TO ACTUALLY IMPROVE
THE COUNTRY AND SOLVE SOME
PROBLEMS.
NANCY PELOSI, SCHUMER, HAVE COME
TO THE CONCLUSION THAT THAT’S
THE ONLY WAY TO BEAT TRUMP IS TO
AVOID IT DEBATES ON HIS
POLICIES, WHICH LET’S FACE IT,
ARE WORKING.
SO WHAT THEY ARE INSTEAD DOING
IS RESORTING TO FULL ON
DEHUMANIZATION AND GUILT BY
ASSOCIATION.
AND SADLY, IT WAS OBVIOUS,
ALMOST FROM THE START THAT TO
THE #MeToo MOVEMENT WOULD
BECOME A MORE ABOUT POLITICS
THAN IT JUSTICE.
THINK ABOUT IT.
JUSTICE REQUIRES MORE THAN AN
ACCUSATION AND A DENIAL.
IT INVOLVES PROBABLE CAUSE, THE
RULES OF EVIDENCE, NOTES HERE
SAY ALOUD, AND THE
CROSS-EXAMINATION OF.
INNOCENT UNTIL PROVEN GUILTY.
NOW, IN SOME CASES, THE EVIDENCE
IS OVERWHELMING.
YOU THINK ABOUT HARVEY
WEINSTEIN, KEVIN SPACEY.
AND THEY ARE DISCUSSING EVEN
CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR, IT WAS WELL
KNOWN BY THE GLITTERATI FOR
DECADES.
BUT AFTER THE TWO WENT OFF TO
REHAB AND TO THE THING REALLY
RAMPED UP, LET’S FACE IT, THE
FOLKS PUSHING THE MOVEMENT
REALLY MOVED ON TO THEIR REAL
TARGET, DONALD J. TRUMP.
>> IF ANYONE KNOWS ABOUT
INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR IN THE
WORKPLACE, IT IS DONALD TRUMP.
IS HE AWARE THAT HE IS HIM?
>> ONE INDUSTRY THAT IS IN A
MINUTE TRYING TO GET RID OF
PREDATORS, AND THAT IS POLITICS.
>> DO YOU WANT TO BE PART OF BU-
>> Laura: REMEMBER, LAST WEEK
A COME OF THE PRESS WITH STORIES
ABOUT THAT GUY, ROB PORTER.
A NAME THAT MOST OF YOU HAD NOT
HEARD OF BEFORE LAST WEEK.
HE’S A FORMER STAFF SECRETARY
WHO HAS BEEN ACCUSED OF TWO
FORMER WIVES AND A RECENT
GIRLFRIEND OF ABUSIVE BEHAVIOR.
HIS REPORTEDLY TUMULTUOUS
RELATIONSHIPS, TO SAY THE LEAST,
APPARENTLY DIDN’T AFFECT HIS
WORK AT, WHICH BY ALL ACCOUNTS
WAS TOP-NOTCH.
EVEN ONE OF HIS EX-WIVES AND
SAID SHE DIDN’T THINK HE SHOULD
BE FIRED, DESPITE WHAT SHE
CLAIMED WERE HIS ANGER PROBLEMS.
AND ON FRIDAY, THE PRESIDENT
REFUSED TO THROW PORTER TO THE
WILLS.
>> FOUND OUT ABOUT IT RECENTLY,
AND I WAS SURPRISED.
WE CERTAINLY WISH HIM WELL.
IT IS OBVIOUSLY A TOUGH TIME FOR
HIM.
HE DID A VERY GOOD JOB WHEN HE
WAS IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
AND WE HOPE HE HAS A WONDERFUL
CAREER, AND HOPEFULLY HE WILL
HAVE A GREAT CAREER AHEAD OF
HIM.
HE IS INNOCENT, AND I THINK YOU
HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT.
HE SAID VERY STRONGLY YESTERDAY
THAT HE IS INNOCENT.
>> Laura: WILL, THAT WAS
HERESY BECAUSE APPARENTLY THE
ONLY ACCEPTABLE RESPONSE FROM
THE PRESIDENT WOULD HAVE BEEN
CONDEMNING PORTER TO A LIFE OF
MISERY AND INVITING THE WIVES TO
THE WHITE HOUSE FOR A #MeToo
LUNCH.
>> HE DOESN’T MERELY TOLERATE
ABUSE, SEXUAL ABUSE IS A VERY
APT METAPHOR FOR EVERYTHING THAT
HE IS.
THIS IS A RAPE CULTURE
PRESIDENT, AND HE HAS BECOME OF
THE CHIEF OF AGE.
>> THIS IS A MISOGYNIST
ADMINISTRATION.
IT IS NOT ABOUT ANYTHING ELSE
MORE THAN A MISOGYNY.
>> HE CONTINUES TO NOT BE FOR OR
SPEAK OUT FOR THE VICTIMS OR THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN ABUSE, BUT
FOR THE ABUSERS.
>> Laura: I THINK THE
PRESIDENT COULD HAVE MENTIONED
THE PEOPLE WHO CLAIM THAT PORTER
DID THAT TO HIM, ABSOLUTELY,
SURE.
HE COULD HAVE MENTIONED IT.
MAYBE PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE, BUT
EXCUSE ME IF I DON’T THINK THAT
THE DEMOCRATS REALLY CARE ALL
THAT MUCH ABOUT WOMEN OR VICTIMS
OF ABUSE AND HARASSMENT.
REMEMBER, FOLKS, THEY CAMPAIGNED
WITH BILL CLINTON, THEY PARTIED
WITH HARVEY, THEY RIDICULED
PAULA JONES, AND 20 TO BRODRICK
IT, AND THEY LOOK THE OTHER
WAY WHEN IT WAS OCCURRING FOR
YEARS BECAUSE IT HELPS THEM
PROFESSIONALLY, PERSONALLY,
POLITICALLY, OR ALL THREE.
IT WAS ONLY WHEN ROSE McGOWAN
EXPOSED THE TRUTH ABOUT ONE
SCENE THAT STARS ARE, PRODUCERS,
DIRECTORS, AND EVEN
HILLARY CLINTON OR FORCED HER TO
ISSUE THERE LATE IN THE GAME
DENUNCIATION.
AND IT DITTO FOR CONFERENCE MY
CONGRESS.
IT WAS NOT UNTIL REPORTS EMERGED
OF THE SETTLEMENTS PAID TO THOSE
ACCUSED.
AND BY THE WAY, WHILE WE ARE ON
THAT, HE WAS FORCED INTO
RETIREMENT OVER HARASSMENT
ALLEGATIONS.
HE WAS THAT WAY FOR YOUR, AND
EVERYBODY KNEW THAT.
SO I ASK YOU, IF THESE DEMOCRATS
CARE SO MUCH ABOUT WOMEN,
ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE YOUNG
WOMEN, WHY DIDN’T ANY OF THEM
SPEAK OUT?
WE ALL KNOW WHY.
NOW, THIS IS REALLY GOOD.
EVEN A SUPREME COURT JUSTICE
SEEMS TO BE HOPPING ON AT THE
BANDWAGON, CITING A TOXIC
TESTOSTERONE FILLED ATMOSPHERE
FOR HILLARY’S ELECTION LAWS.
>> I THINK IT WAS DIFFICULT FOR
HILLARY CLINTON TO GET BY THE
MACHO ATMOSPHERE PREVAILING
DURING THAT CAMPAIGN.
ANYBODY WHO WATCHED THAT
CAMPAIGN UNFOLD WOULD FEEL THE
SAME WAY THAT I DO.
SEXISM PLAYED A PROMINENT PART.
>> Laura: I’M SURE SHE CANNOT
DECIDE ANY CASE INVOLVING TRUMP.
THIS IS AN OUTRAGE.
SHE HAS BASICALLY BECOME A
POLITICAL PUNDIT.
LOOK OUT, RACHEL MADDOW, SHE
COULD HAVE HER OWN SHOW ON
MSNBC.
AND THEN THERE WAS 20 TWENTIETHS
DEMOCRAT HOPEFUL, NEW YORK
SENATE, KRISTEN GILLIBRAND.
>> I THINK HE SHOULD RESIGN, AND
IF HE IS UNWILLING TO DO THAT,
THEN CONGRESS SHOULD HOLD HIM
ACCOUNTABLE.
WE ARE OBLIGATED TO HAVE
HEARINGS.
>> Laura: HAS SHE EVER RETURNS
THAT THE MONEY THAT’S
BILL CLINTON RATES FOR HER?
I DOUBT IT.
LOOK AT, SHE HAS FULLY WEAPONIZE
WEAPONIZE --
FULLY WEAPONIZE THE #MeToo A
MOMENT, WITH THE INTENTION OF
DRIVING THE FEMALE VOTE IN THE
MIDTERM.
AND ULTIMATELY, SWEEPING HERSELF
RIGHT INTO THE OVAL OFFICE.
AND WHILE WE ALL CONDEMN ACTUAL
ABUSE, REGARDLESS OF WHERE IT
OCCURS, THE LAST TIME THAT I
CHARGE, JOBS, THE ECONOMY,
HEALTH CARE, EDUCATION WHERE IT
STILL THE TOP ISSUES FOR VOTERS,
INCLUDING WOMEN.
NONETHELESS, LET’S FACE IT.
A SHIFT MAY BE UNDERWAY.
ESPECIALLY AMONG YOUNGER VOTERS.
TED CRUZ UPSET OVER THE WEEKENDS
THAT’S THE LEFT WOULD CRAWL OVER
BROKEN GLASS TO VOTE IN THE
MIDTERMS.
THINKING ABOUT IT, HE IS
PROBABLY RIGHT.
AND IF GILLIBRAND HAS HER WAY,
MOST OF THOSE WITH CUTS ON THEIR
HANDS AND KNEES ARE GOING TO BE
WOMEN.
THE LEFT IS REALLY BUSY
MARSHALING THEIR ALLIES, THEIR
RESOURCES, ACROSS THE CULTURAL
AND POLITICAL SPECTRUM TO MAKE
THE PRESIDENT TOXIC TO WOMEN.
AND ULTIMATELY DRIVE HIM FROM
OFFICE.
AND THE PRESIDENT HAS ALREADY
SEEN SOME EROSION AND HIS FEMALE
SUPPORT.
THE DEMOCRATS KNOW THIS IS A
MAGIC BULLET FOR THEM.
IF THEY TURN THE WOMEN’S VOTE,
BY JUST A FEW PERCENTAGE POINTS,
IT CAN MEAN THE DIFFERENCE IN
THE MIDTERMS AND IN 2020.
BUT I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
THIS IS BY ALL MEANS NOT A LOST
CAUSE.
THAT IS NOT WHAT I’M SAYING,
CONTRARY TO WHAT MSNBC AND CNN
WOULD HAVE YOU BELIEVE.
MOST WOMEN WANT GREATER ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES, THEY WANT SAFE
STREETS, THEY WANT SOLID PUBLIC
SCHOOLS FOR THEIR KIDS, AND THEY
WANT HEALTH CARE THAT COVERS THE
BASIC STUFF.
THAT IS FOR MOST OF US.
AND THE PRESIDENT IS DOING MORE
ON ALL OF THOSE FRIENDS THEN I
THINK THE PASTOR TO PRESENT
COMBINED.
AND HE NEEDS TO SELL THIS
DIRECTLY TO THE VOTERS,
INCLUDING WOMEN VOTERS.
DIRECTLY.
BUT TONE MATTERS, ESPECIALLY
WITH WOMEN.
IT IS NOT JUST WHAT YOU SAY BUT
HOW YOU SAY IT.
AND SOMETIMES, IT IS ALSO WHAT
YOU FAIL TO SAY.
THAT CAN BE JUST AS IMPORTANT AS
WHAT YOU DO SAY.
SO IF HE COMES ON TOO STRONG, OR
TO DEFENSIVELY, AND IT TWEETS OR
AN OFF-THE-CUFF EXCHANGE WITH
REPORTERS, HE COULD SET HIMSELF
BACK.
AND HE COULD CONFIRM THE UNFAIR
CARICATURE OF THE LEFT PROMOTES